Welcome to our project
Google Developers Hackademy,
where Spanish-speaking experts
from Latin America
will show you some
our tools,
developer products,
APIs and new tricks.
This course is divided
into five parts.
We invite you to watch it
and learn along.
Here we go.
Welcome to the HTML5
web developing
with Google Drive
introduction course.
I'm Cesar Anton Dorantes,
Google Developer Expert
for the Google Drive platform.
In this lesson we'll do a review
of the main concepts
we saw throughout this course:
HTML5 main characteristics.
File structure in HTML5 apps.
Sharing files and folders
with Google Drive.
Introduction to Google Charts.
Introduction to
Google Spreadsheets
and Connecting your app
with Google Spreadsheets.
You ready? Here we go!
In lesson 1 we saw:
HTML5 file structure,
where we learned
the overall structure
for this documents.
File structure in HTML5 apps.
This is where we reviewed
how to place files
for HTML apps.
Free web hosting using
Google Drive Public Folders.
Here we learned to use
Google Drive
to save our sheets for free.
Automated sync
with Google Drive.
This helped us learn
how to use Google Drive
to keep our data cloud-synced
in an automatic manner.
And finally,
we performed a practice
where we built
our first HTML5 app
hosted on Google Drive.
In lesson 2 we covered:
Introduction to Google Charts,
where we presented to you
the main features
of Google Charts.
My first chart
with Google Table Charts,
where we learned to do
a very basic chart
using manually entered
information.
Google Pie Charts.
We learned to transform
that information
into a pie chart.
Y finally,
we performed a practice
where we built an HTML5 app
with Google Charts.
In lesson 3 we learned:
Introduction to
Google Spreadsheets,
where we saw
the general features
and how Google Spreadsheets
allows programmers
to create databases
easy to interpret.
Connecting your app
with Google Spreadsheets,
where we learned to connect
Google Charts
with the information
from Spreadsheets in real time.
And finally,
we performed a practice
where we connected our HTML5 app
to Google's Cloud.
In lesson 4 we covered
the following subjects:
Creating a new Google Cloud
Console project,
which is you starting point
to develop with Google.
Activating G+ API,
which is needed to be able
to use Google+ Login button.
How to register an app
on Google's Cloud,
the features of the
Google+ Login button,
and finally,
how to add the G+ Login button
to HTML5 applications.
This will be it
for this course review.
I hope you enjoyed it
as much as I did
and that it inspires you
to create big HTML5 projects.
If you wish to talk to me
about any subject
regarding HTML web developing,
don't hesitate to search me
on my Google+ profile,
directly by my name.
I hope I'll see you soon
and remember:
keep on programming.